do you because I you know on this
project you say that you're the the
queen of the bay which I mean yeah
well you know I'm not like you're like
the queen of California
you know I went to USC right I mean I
mean I don't want to self-proclaim my my
the queen statement but when I'm in
certain cities or I'm in certain areas
they'll just like call me this and call
me that and I've been called the queen
of California I've been called many
Queen things but I don't think it was
more of a
like it's not something that like I'm
trying to title that's why I had another
voice that say it you know I don't like
when people like self-proclaim sometimes
I mean listen little Wayne called
himself the best rapper alive as he
should though and T.I said he was the
Kayla South as he should though but when
TI said that everybody was like who the
[ __ ] is this guy because it was like I
think it was on the second album he said
that on uh uh
trap music right trap music
um but yeah I think you know it's okay
to just you because who else is going to
do that all right no but I feel like as
they should because they had you know a
catalog but because I'm just heating
back up again you know I appreciate the
titles but I still feel like I got
something to prove right and queen is a
big statement it is a big stick it's a
huge statement yeah that's fair